c'est la rentrée demain 13 millions
d'élèves recommence à travailler 700
mille francs qu'ils ont déjà prêté dès
aujourd'hui la fuite vers l'ouest des
allemands de l'est via la frontière
austro hongrois av
un exode qui pose beaucoup de problèmes
à l'anniversaire pour qui l'ignorerait
son 100ème film lavit et rien d'autre de
bertrand tavernier clip est le premier
la guerre à outrance du gouvernement
colombien contre les parrains de la
drogue dans ce journal reportage
exclusif de notre envoyé spécial
brunoise bonsoir tout est prêt vos
cartables vos cahiers vos crayons vos
gants mais aussi vos chewing gum
pourquoi pas vous avez encore quelques
heures en tout cas car demain c'est la
rentrée pour un français sur quatre près
de 13 millions d'écoliers lycéens qui
retourne sur leur banc préférez ceux de
l'école sans compter le million de
professeurs pour vous faire souffrir et
d'ailleurs ces profils étaient déjà
rentrés aujourd'hui pour préparer vos
souffrances problème est question de
cette rentrée 89
chantal qui meurt il y aura t'il demain
un professeur dans chaque classe
à grigny dans l'essonne pour ce collège
tout neuf pas de mauvaise surprise
c'est une bonne rentrée des classes des
profs pour toutes les classes des
classes à 26 27 élèves maximum eu un
dialogue serein entre le principal et
les enseignants s'est engagé à la veille
du grand jour
bref rien n'est à craindre pour
l'arrivée des élèves demain matin
pourtant derrière cette tranquillité
quelques états d'âme s'exprime je pense
que c'est surtout si l'opinion et
l'image des professeurs pour besoin d
être bien revalorisé aussi au niveau des
familles et ça on s'est aussi important
les qualités de vie ils ont ce que j'ai
peur c'est que pour avoir des avantages
financiers en fasse des concessions et
des régressions sur le plan de la
qualité de travail et ça c'est assez
dangereux c'est le problème numéro un de
cette rentrée la qualité de travail est
mise en cause par la surcharge des
classes selon les syndicats par tous les
plannings sont saturés les lycées crack
38-39 jusqu'à 40 élèves
la plupart des 1re et terminale presque
toutes les régions sont touchées par une
scolarisation intensive des oies 19
élèves je vous assure qu'ils seront
reçus au bac avec notre brillant l'an
dernier 30
ils sont certainement moins brillant et
puis de toute façon je vais les
connaître encore à noël je reconnaîtrais
sans doute 19
et puis à la fin de l'année ya encore un
petit d'un physique pas très
exceptionnel que je n'aurais pas encore
découvert c'est comme ça alors on peut
tout enseigner mais on en fait dans de
très mauvaises conditions et les
résultats sont probants alors de cela on
va reparler ce soir sur antenne 2 à
20h35 car l'événement politique c'est
sur antenne 2 c'est l'heure de vérité de
françois henri de virieu qui reprend
avec comme invité ce soir le ministre de
l'éducation
lionel jospin monsieur juste un bon soir
alors moi pendant combien de temps
encore on va voir des classes à 39
élèves comme ça vient le premier
ministre michel rocard a fixé un
objectif qui est dans les lycées en 1993
pas de classe au dessus de 35 élèves
je crois que c'est une direction dans
laquelle nous devons aller car il est
clair que plus les classes sont
surchargées plus les difficiles pour les
élèves de t'apprendre et pour les
professeurs d'enseigner dans de bonnes
conditions
encore que un lycée dans un bon quartier
avec des élèves sélectionnés et un lycée
dans un quartier plus difficile justifie
pas tout à fait les mêmes effectifs plus
c'est difficile - il faudrait qu'elle
élève oui mais en moyenne c'est quoi le
bon nombre dans une classe eh bien je
viens de vous répondre il faut de toute
façon éviter que on dépasse 35 dans les
lycées c'est l'objectif qu'on doit se
fixer parce que dans les lycées ya la
vague dans le primaire actuellement en
maternelle ce sont des effectifs qui
sont autour de 28 29 et dans le primaire
ce sont des effectifs qui sont à 23,24
dans les lycées on peut pas arriver à
des effectifs de ce type pour le moment
compte tenu de ce qu'est la vague
démographique et l' envie d'apprendre
des jeunes et les familles merci lire l
instant vous retrouve tout de suite dans
l'heure de vérité à 20h35 aussitôt après
ce journal ce sera peut-être le fait
diplomatique majeur de cette année 89 la
rue et de milliers d'allemands de l'est
qui s'en vont vers l'ouest depuis la
construction du mur de berlin c'est à
dire au début des années 50
les allemands de l'est étaient condamnés
à
rester de l'autre côté du rideau de fer
mais le rideau de fer on l'a vu c'est
entre ouvert cette année entre
l'autriche et la hongrie et des milliers
de réfugiés d'allemagne de l'est qui
engouffrent il se pourrait d'ailleurs
qu'un accord intervienne entre les deux
allemagnes sur le départ d'autres
milliers de réfugiés
pour l'instant les ceux qui s'en vont
parce dans la semi-clandestinité
l'équipe d'antenne 2 avec dominique
derda fait rendu des deux côtés de cette
frontière
reportage un mirador tous les 200 mètres
puis un vaste no man's land
les patrouilles permanentes la frontière
du de hongrie semble infranchissable
pourtant tous les jours des dizaines
d'allemands de l'est ce passe en
autriche à cet endroit le parking de
faire tu auras cause c'est ici que se
retrouvent fugitif et passeur passeur
bénévoles et passeur professionnels qui
demandent parfois jusqu'à 3500 francs
par personne pour leur indiquer
l'itinéraire le plus sûr à travers les
mailles du rideau de fer
la frontière n'est qu'à un kilomètre
yoann à 38 ans il attend le moment
propice pour tenter de placer à l'ouest
voici ma voiture que je vais être obligé
de les séries si tout ce que j'emporte
avec moi
ces cinq ans et que contient-il ce sac
chaussures un pantalon
quelques affaires personnelles comment
comptez vous faire pour passer la
frontière risque en une heure à pied on
peut traverser des champs et la forêt et
son filet travers les barbelés à
musicalarue pas peur bien sûr que j'ai
peur mais j'ai tout laissé derrière moi
alors il est trop tard pour renoncer
comme yoran les fugitifs est-allemands
tout abandonné derrière eux pour
n'emporter que l'essentiel au grand
bonheur des hongrois des environs qui
trouvent ainsi du matériel de camping et
des pièces détachées à profusion
car ici aussi comme en allemagne de
l'est c'est la pénurie les gens les
villages ont tous récupéré tout ce que
les allemands de l'est ont les serres et
en sont ils ces allemands partis vers la
frontière là bas cinq heures du matin
côté autrichien passeur et membre de la
croix rouge attend les réfugiés aux
principaux points de passage
attention frontière d'état
le rideau de fer le voit si je suis ici
en hongrie est devant moi un énorme trou
c'est par ici que se sont enfuis des
centaines d'allemands de l'est en
direction de l'autriche
je traverse le rideau de fer me voici en
autriche
le premier village et à quelques
kilomètres c'est la sela qu'attendent
les gens de la croix-rouge autrichienne
c'est là qu'ils attendent ces réfugiés
est allemand pour les conduire ensuite
en allemagne de l'ouest
ce matin ce sont des roumains qui ont
pris la clé des champs
le chemin qui mène à l'autriche commence
à être connu dans tout le bloc de l'est
deux heures à peine après l'avoir
quittée en hongrie nous retrouverons
yoan en autriche
il est passé sans encombre il ne m'a pas
fallu plus de vingt minutes ça a été un
jeu d'enfant
à travers les champs les vignes la forêt
et le barbelé
cette patrouille hongroise de garde
il était très gentil mais demain tu es
un clin d'oeil
yoann est aujourd'hui en allemagne de
l'ouest
il a retrouvé son fils et sa fiancée
toute une série d'accidents d'avion ces
dernières 24 heures le dernier en date
l'accident d'un fokker de la sécurité
civile il s'est écrasé tout à l'heure en
fin d'après midi près d'alès dans le
gard il luttait contre les incendies de
forêts il y avait deux personnes à bord
à cuba c'est une catastrophe aérienne de
grande ampleur 125 morts dans l'accident
d'un iliouchine 62 la plupart des
passagers étaient des touristes italiens
véronique gallière l'accablement la
consternation
l'incertitude des parents des proches
venus attendre à milan l'avion de la
vanne viennent d'apprendre qu'ils ne
verront plus jamais l'un des leurs les
113 passagers italiens de l'iliouchine
soviétique était venu passer une semaine
de vacances à cuba pour un prix charter
défiant toute concurrence
tous ont péri carbonisés dans la
terrible explosion
un seul passager survécu il est dans un
état désespéré
l'avion venait de décoller lorsqu'il a
heurté des lignes à haute tension
la pluie battante pourrait être à
l'origine de l'accident il s'est écrasé
dans un quartier résidentiel de la
havane 19 maisons en miettes
soixante deux personnes blessées au sol
le président fidel castro s'est aussitôt
rendu sur les lieux
cette catastrophe aérienne est la plus
meurtrière qu'ait jamais connu la havane
mais ce n'est pas fini dans cette série
noire loin de là au brésil un boeing de
l'avarice et la compagnie brésilienne
s'est écrasé en pleine jungle
on ne l'a pas retrouvée il ya 54
disparus dans la région de
thonon-les-bains en haute-savoie ce sont
deux avions de tourisme qui se sont
écrasés
là encore trois morts 100 disparus et
puis enfin ce dernier ce dernier
accident je vous jure que ce sera tout
pour aujourd'hui
cela se passe au dessus du lac ontario
regarder entre les etats-unis et le
canada deux avions qui se sont acheté
les avions de la patrouille acrobatique
de l'aviation canadienne
ils se sont heurtés du bout des ailes
l'un des pilotes a été tué le second a
pu s'éjecter de son papa
bonjour peugeot alors des limousines à
son tour la firme de sochaux sort une
voiture haut de gamme c'est la 605
peugeot n'est pas le seul constructeur
français agir ainsi tous les
constructeurs misent sur des voitures de
luxe destinée à concurrencer les grosses
d'allemandes met d'abord en exclusivité
voici les premières images de la 605
alain douguet ce qui équilibre des
masses mode et des volumes c'est la 605
décrit par son constructeur la
documentation évoque ensuite noblesse et
puissance du moteur
wima des portières silhouette puissant
généreuse et même cossu 26 ans 5 propose
à partir du milieu de gamme moteur v6
freinage abs assistance variable de la
direction gestion électronique des
amortisseurs
tout cela afin de concurrencer les
belles étrangères allemandes suédoise ou
italienne
arrivé à ce niveau de prix le client
exige du solide blessures mais aussi du
rêve c'est le retour du carrosse mais
j'en envie d'exister plus de participer
à une sorte de modèle attractif qui est
le retour d'une certaine élite nous
bourgeoisie cossu bien installé ce
marché représente 14 % du parc européen
tellement fabrique la majeure partie
c'est-à-dire 64%
les suédois 13 % les français 11 puis
viennent les italiens anglais et
japonais
il ya quelques mois seulement sortait la
xm de citroën dans la foulée donc et
dans la même catégorie
la peugeot 605 est ce bien raisonnable
je crois que l'offre française sur les
véhicules de haut de gamme était est
encore insuffisante je pense qu'il est
tout à fait normal et naturel que
chacune des trois marques françaises
offrent à la clientèle française un
véhicule de haut de gamme
l'augmentation des ventes de voitures
haut de gamme paraît s'inscrire dans un
contexte plus général d'un renouveau des
produits de luxe du moins pour une
certaine catégorie de français
nous constatons que après la crise il y
a de fait une très grande demande plus
de qualité pour plus innovation pour
plus de tradition et pour plus de
sécurité sécurité qui est donné par les
grandes marques
les grands noms la réputation des
produits de luxe français n'est plus à
faire sauf précisément pour les
automobiles haut de gamme là beaucoup de
chemin reste à parcourir
la colombie où les troubles ne cesse pas
depuis que le gouvernement a déclaré la
guerre aux parrains de la drogue
aujourd'hui encore il ya eu de nouveaux
attentats une explosion hier soir
medellin une bombe qui a fait cinq
blessés
et puis ce matin c'est une fusillade qui
a éclaté à l'aéroport de cette même
ville faisant deux morts et douze
blessés dont trois policiers
au même moment les américains font
parvenir des renforts et du matériel
militaire pour aider les autorités de
bogota
bruno alba l'envoyé spécial d'antenne 2
est en colombie propre avec leur
cargaison d'équipement secrets et de
pièces de rechange ces deux avions de
l'armée américaine sont le premier
cadeau des états unis à la colombie pour
l'aider à mener sa guerre contre les
trafiquants de drogue
l'armée colombienne recevra encore ce
soir lui avions de chasse et demain cinq
hélicoptères de combat des techniciens
militaires américains participeront à
l'instruction des pilotes columbia huit
jours après la déclaration de guerre
entre le gouvernement de bogota et des
rois de la drogue
ce matériel sera immédiatement envoyé
sur le terrain transport de troupes mais
aussi missions de bombardement des
aéroports clandestins utilisés par les
trafiquants
c'est bien d'opérations de guerre dont
il s'agit gardée secrète par l'armée
mais qui correspondent à la volonté des
américains de frapper à tous les niveaux
pour la cocaïne contre les drogues et
toujours été et sera toujours une lutte
contre la production et de lutte pour
éliminer la demande
l'aide américaine arrive à point nommé
les trafiquants n'ont pas attendu
longtemps pour mettre leur menace à
exécution
ici à bogota un camion bourré
d'explosifs a explosé avant-hier à 7
heures du matin sur le parking d'une
station service tout ce qui se trouvait
alentours a été volatilisé
une personne a été tuée 73 ont été
blessés un attentat en forme
d'avertissement pour ceux qui
soutiennent le gouvernement dans la
guerre déclarée aux trafiquants el
espectador le journal a été totalement
ravagé son directeur a déjà été
assassiné par le cartel de medellin il y
a trois ans il prend régulièrement des
positions sans équivoque
mais si les journalistes affirme vouloir
poursuivre dans la même voie des
attentats comme celui ci ébranle
fortement la population et il faut
dialoguer avec les trafiquants ceux qui
souffrent
ce sont les gens du peuple colombien il
est inadmissible que des gens innocents
passants dans la rue à un moment donné
soit les victimes d'une bombe
il faut qu'on dialogue il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose il faut que ce
gouvernement agisse cet homme est un
magistrat un juge réputé incorruptible
il vit sous la menace depuis des mois
aujourd'hui alberto médina renonce les
cartels colombiens ont juré d'assassiner
sa fille s'il poursuit sa tâche alors il
s'apprête à laisser à son successeur d'
énorme dossier d'instruction trafic
meurtres et corruption
un pays ne peut pas s'en sortir
démocratique ou non quand la justice a
peur quand elle n'est pas indépendante
quand le juge ne peut pas être souverain
dans ses actes quand il ne peut pas
représenter la majesté de la justice il
ne peut pas remplir sa mission quand les
armes des assassins le menace quand on
tire sur lui dès que l'on conteste son
action ouest c'était hier au cimetière
de bogota ces militaires sont chargés de
la sécurité de l'un des candidats à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
ernesto samper qui assistaient aux
obsèques de son cousin
c'était pourtant dimanche les portes du
cimetière sont restés fermés à la
population jusqu'à 4 heures de l'après
midi
ernesto samper soutient officiellement
la guerre déclenchée par le gouvernement
contre les rois de la drogue
un peu plus loin une autre tombe et une
famille venue se recueillir celle de
luis carlos gallan le candidat assassiné
il y a deux semaines
ça tombait chaque jour couverte de
fleurs apportées par les habitants de
bogota son assassinat à souder toute une
partie de la colombie de la mort de luis
carlos a réveillé ce pays devant un
danger un danger non seulement pour la
colombie mais aussi pour le monde en
général cela aussi réveillé le reste des
nations pour qu'ils voient la lutte
gigantesque et la colombie livres contre
ce fléau de l'humanité
les trafiquants multiplient les
attentats à bogota et medellin contre
les édifices publics les universités les
intérêts américains
le père de louise carlos galana raison
la guerre ne fait que commencer
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
de l'actualité internationale notamment
un attentat à londres véronique taveau
attentat anti rushdie à londres une
bombe de faible puissance a explosé hier
soir devant le magasin liberty est la
librairie penguin une femme a été
blessée aux jambes deux autres ont été
plus légèrement
peu avant l'explosion scotland yard
avait été prévenu un correspondant
anonyme avait mentionné le livre de
salman rushdie les versets sataniques
ont été publiés l'an dernier dans la
collection penguin c'est la troisième
fois que des librairies pendant le livre
de salman rushdie sont la cible
d'attentats à londres
lech walesa n'est pas d'accord et il le
dit le numéro 1 de solidarité s'est
publiquement élevé contre l'accord
conclu samedi dernier entre le premier
ministe addow mazowiecki et la direction
du pouf
selon cet accord le parti communiste
polonais obtiendrait plus de deux
ministères dans le nouveau gouvernement
le président de solidarité a déclaré que
les membres du gouvernement devaient
être désignés en fonction de leur
réputation de réformateur
indépendamment de leur appartenance
politique
44 chefs d'état douch chef de
gouvernement le 9ème sommet des pays non
alignés s'est ouvert ce matin à belgrade
deux absences remarquées celles de fidel
castro et du roi hassan ii du maroc
le numéro à yugo ce clavier neige trône
au tchèque le nouveau président a dès
l'ouverture du sommet réclamé que la
tenue d'une conférence nord-sud au menu
des débats qui doivent se poursuivre
jusqu'à jeudi
la dette le terrorisme et la détente est
ouest
les joueurs je veux parler de ceux qui
aiment jouer ne savent plus où donner de
la tête après le tac au tac le cache le
surf et j'en passe sûrement
voici le 421 c'est un nouveau jeu
instantané
lancé par france loto il paraît qu'on a
une chance sur quatre de gagner
l'explication de fibois free il coche il
gratte il angoisse il compulse pour 18
milliards de francs chaque année les
français consomment du loto à gogo un
succès qui ne décourage pas la société
francelot tôt d'inventer de nouveaux
jeux dernier-né les instantanés le cash
en avril le surf en juin et aujourd'hui
le 421 des petits frères qui se
ressemblent comme deux gouttes d'eau il
n'y a pas de différence c'est le
seulement le thème qui change les
rapports sont pareils
et pourquoi alors on change de thème on
change de thème pour relancer la vente
et ça marche plus de 170 millions de
tickets de cacher de sorte vendus un
résultat qui a fait augmenter le chiffre
d'affaires du loto de plus de 15% au
moins tiens ton là un vrai gagnant pour
jouer c'est tout simple misés 10 francs
et gratter 421 à part et vous voilà la
tête de cent mille francs 3d de même
valeur peuvent vous rapporter de tif à
dix mille francs le jeu est ouvert à
tous il n'y a pas d'âge pour y goûter
petit tour d'horizon de l'actualité
sportive de ce lundi avec jean ma mère
où l'on voit réapparaître quelques stars
prématurément disparu
maradona existe les journalistes
italiens l'ont enfin vu arriver à rome
et puis yannick noah joue encore au
tennis et oui il est qualifié pour les
quarts de finale de l'us open
depuis le temps qu'on attendait il est
enfin arrivé maradona débarqué à rome
via madrid
l'arlésienne ne pouvait faire moins
voitures blanches au pied de l'avion et
centaines de photographes et cameramen
enfin de la tente
malheureusement cette dernière fut
longue et peu fructueuse
maradona petit sourire aux lèvres ne
s'est finalement pas décidé pour une
conférence de presse cette bombe
lacrymogène lancée au visage du gardien
chine hier risque d'avoir des
conséquences plus graves que la légère
blessure qu'elle a occasionnée les
chiliens
mené 1 à 0 lors de l'incident ont quitté
le terrain et refusé de reprendre la
partie après celui de careca le match a
donc été suspendue les chiliens
demandent aujourd'hui l'annulation de la
rencontre
la qualification de la coupe du monde en
dépend ou bien de rejouer le match mais
sur un terrain neutre
il est vrai que le stade de maracana
archicomble cela a de quoi faire peur
noah revient efforts face à l'italien
monsigny il a retrouvé son tennis comme
aux plus beaux jours
rageur offensif et volleyeurs efficace
même s'il a souffert noah ne l'a emporté
qu'au cinquième set le français a défié
tous les pronostics
personne n'aurait misé sur lui terrifié
pour les quarts de finale désormais les
difficultés s'amplifient noah rencontre
au prochain tour voorhees becker une
victoire ferait sans aucun doute parler
alors de résurrection
le cinéma maintenant avec notre invité
c'est philippe noiret je voulais
présenter dans les titres tout à l'heure
bonsoir philippe noiret conçoit alors
vous êtes là parce qu'un nouveau de film
sort celui de bertrand tavernier qui
s'appelle la vie et rien d'autre mais
surtout si vous habitez c'est parce que
c'est votre centième film oui j'ai
vraiment mais oui justement talonne pas
ainsi que si la donne un coup de vieux
mais je réagi vivement dont on les voit
pas passer c'est comme le temps on
aurait vu et on va jouer je vais aligner
quelques banalités comme d'habitude
quand on aborde ce sujet mais c'est vrai
on ne se rend pas compte si j'avais pas
eu un biographe attentif faire parler
attentionné et m'a dit et le film de
bertrand ces deux centièmes alors alors
dites pas que vous devez être content
parce que alors là les critiques sont
dithyrambiques
oui j'ai vu par exemple dans l'express
je sais plus qui écrivez ça philippe
noiret qui est l'un des plus grands
acteurs du monde c'est ça oui j'ai lu ça
aussi moi oui c'était pas temps non oui
à vous faites vite on fait ce qu elle a
dit on vous pouvez attendre les
libérations sa délibération une crache
dessus depuis 15 ans la ben oui oui
c'est vraiment les seuls non ça fait
tâche d'huile en ce moment mais c'est
pas grave je suis là je m'accroche je
vais encore faire sans et il faudra
qu'ils s'y habituent
on va reparler de vous bien sûr mais le
film quand même ma vie vous ai rien
dorémieux parler du film bertrand
tavernier alors raconté un petit peu de
quoi il s'agit c'est une histoire c'est
une histoire d'amour qui se passe en
1920 après la guerre de 14 entre 1
militaire de carrière que j'interprète
qui est chargée de diriger le bureau de
recherche et d'identification des
militaires disparus car il ya eu trois
cent cinquante mille disparus en plus
d'un million six cent mille morts en
14-18 est aussi et est aussi de
retrouver et de retrouver aussi le
soldat inconnu il est chargé de ne pas
de le retrouver mais d'en choisir un qui
soit comme disait la hiérarchie
militaire à l'époque surtout denis 1
bosch ni un angliche et surtout pas un
[ __ ]
ça aurait fait ça aurait fait désordre à
ce moment là alors c'est un problème
voilà comme quoi il ya à la fois et
c'est une histoire d'amour avec une
femme qui a perdu quel dont le mari est
disparue et qui va de bureaux et 2 e en
bureaux et de pitau en hôpitaux essayer
d'avoir des traces de son mari disparu
est un film anti militariste
non pas du tout c'est un film anti
guerre un de plus vous me direz c'est
tout le monde est contre la guerre mais
enfin là c'est un film sur la vie comme
le titre l'indiqué la vie et rien
d'autre c'est un film qui est donc une
histoire d'amour qui se passe sur ce sur
ce terrain de ruines et de souffrance
d'après la guerre de 14 mai je vous
propose ensuite d'en voir un extrait mes
amis y voyons un expérimenté dernier
on a tout tenté pour aujourd'hui
j'adresserai une note 2 félicitations à
vous chers avec demande de permission
exceptionnelle
merci
s'il officie vous ressemblez les hommes
retour au camp nou
passant devant
alors fait ce que nous pouvions parce
que votre nous manquions c'est que
c'était
toutes sortes de raisons
voilà les chaînes pour dégager
le gage de quoi d'ailleurs la boue et
des sons
voilà un extrait de ce film alors
philippe noiret vous parliez tout à
l'heure de votre biographie parce
qu'effectivement à l'occasion de ce 100e
film il ya un monsieur qui s'appelle
dominique mallet qui a écrit un livre
sur vous s'intitule en toute simplicité
philippe noiret oui il a pensé que
c'était plus simple et en toute
simplicité il ya une préface de françois
mitterrand sein de vos amis non non non
oui c'est dominique mayega écrit c'est
pas une biographie c'est un livre sur
les 100 films auxquels j'ai participés
quoi et dominique mallet est un grand
timide et comme tous les grands timides
il a des pulsions irrésistibles comme ça
il a été pris un peu de mégalomanie et
l'a demandé au président de la
république d'écrire une introduction si
ce n'est une préface et celui ci a
accepté après avoir dit qu'il était un
peu occupé par les élections d'abord et
ensuite par le sommet et mais il l'a
fait et bien évidemment j'ai été très
touché et par le geste et par les termes
employés
je vais vous dire ce qui semble un peu
inquiétant dans votre cas sauf que vous
parliez tout à l'heure de libération
mais c'est justement ne dit jamais du
mal depuis six ans c'est très très rare
non sur des pommes
ceux-ci mérimée temps c'est inquiétant
oui remarquez c'est confortable d'un
autre côté mais non depuis 5 6 ans
pendant une quinzaine d'années j'ai été
tout à fait toujours encensé puis le
plus cinq ou six ans une sas nuance
c'est très bien comme ça on dit beaucoup
que je fais du noir est souvent ça ça
revient et vous vous dites beaucoup que
vous aimeriez être un honnête homme et
moi j'en élections vous êtes trop poli
pour être sûrement oui je cache sûrement
des noirceurs 1 que seul mais intime
connaissent savent il ya un très joli
mobile fusant je me parlait encore qu'il
ya très haut niveau de frais bogaert à
qui on disait ça nous ennuie pas de
jouer toujours des rôle à la bogart u10
est de toute façon c'est moi qui les
jouent le mieux
ce que je trouve une très belle réponse
merci et lui ce que vous êtes un homme
cultivé vous ne serez pas surpris des
nouveaux mots qui entre cette année dans
le petit larousse ce petit larousse
vient de sortir le bois ciselé à côté de
moi je le prends de ce bras je voulais
le voici alors pêle-mêle on trouve dans
ce petit larousse 90 la glace note par
exemple les narcodollars les
juilletistes c'est ceux qui partent en
vacances en juillet et puis surtout
antenne 2 et oui nous sommes dans le
dictionnaire youpi présentation du petit
larousse 90
sylvie marion puisque antenne 2 entre
cette année dans le petit larousse ce
tabernacle de la langue française
faisons entrer le petit larousse à
antenne 2 pour voir ce qu'on en dit
quand même on est un peu cher mais oui
il ya de quoi être fier entrer dans le
saint des saints du dictionnaire c'est
ça la consécration à de l'antenne de
société nationale de programme de
télévision française constituée en 1974
elle est issue de la deuxième chaîne mis
en service en 1964 oui c'est bon une
définition ce n'est jamais drôle ça
c'est sûr mais quand est la place que
nous occupons nous voilà en tête s'il
vous plaît d'accord c'est tout
l'audiovisuel qui est honorée cette fois
est bien sur antenne 2 commence par un a
mais quand même il ya là comme un
symbole antenne de 10 les sondages est
elle pas la préférée de tous ça modifie
complètement ma perception
dictionnaire comme réservoir culturel
allons bon une fausse note vite rattrapé
heureusement ce choix a à 2 elle
comprend deux montées et le spécialiste
des médias qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de
sa antenne 2 qui entre pour le petit
larousse c'est à dire que nous avons des
chances de durer
j'espère en tout cas les présidents
passent rim et puis nous en étudions la
voilà il ya encore des pronostics pour
le tiercé qui se court demain à
longchamp voici ce que vous propose
pierrette brès le 12 le 14 le neuf le 4
le 5 le 2 le 11 et le 7 c'est à
longchamp je vous le disais pour la fin
de cette édition tout de suite la météo
avec sophie davant henri sannier vous
présentera la dernière édition du
journal vers minuit puis demain comme
d'habitude 6h30 télématin et m'a dit tu
rames et gérard morin qui présente les
journaux dans télématin à traver ce sera
william leymergie patricia charnolé
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
20 heures